بتزامن مع الاحداث الدائره في مخيم جنين
لا تزال اصوات المناهضه تعلو شوارع
اسرائيل بسبب خطه الحكومه للتعديلات
القضائيه حيث اغلق المتظاهرون لفتره وجيزه
الطرق المؤديه الى ميناء بحري هام قبل
تجمع للحشود في المطار الرئيسي واغلق
عشرات المتظاهرين بعضهم يرفعون العلم
الاسرائيلي والبعض الاخر يقرعون الطبول
بوابه ميناء حيفا في الشمال لمده ساعه
ونصف الساعه في وقت لم تثمر محاولات رئيس
الوزراء بنيام نتانياهو لتهدئه بعض
الاحتياجات خلال محادثات للتسويه مع
المعارضه ونظرا لان الائتلاف حكومه
نتنياهو الدينيه القوميه يتمتع باغلبيه
برلمانيه مريحه ينظم المعارضون المزيد من
الاحتياجات في الشوارع في محاوله لمنع
التغييرات التي يرون انها تهدد استقلال
القضاء في اسرائيل وبنيه الدوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات